the first thing that immediately stood
out to me about wildstar was its
aesthetic at times it's an absolutely
gorgeous game the colors are bright and
inviting all sorts of hand-drawn
frippery brings an ornate joy to each
area herds of ghazal light grazers
elegantly leap across the screen with
such a rich looking world I'm drawn to
explore it because I might find
something unexpected if you look at it
see bright colors and exaggerated shapes
and immediately compare it to world of
warcraft you're missing out on the
bigger picture in actuality wildstar's
art design is not a whole lot like Laos
but something very much its own the
second thing that stood out to me about
wildstar is that that same art style
that makes it attractive at certain
times makes it look cluttered at other
times everything draws your eye to it
the swirling grass textures the flowers
the hanging lamps the smoking fires the
bubbling lava the dust motes and the
twinkles and the dream catchers and all
the colors of the rainbow one moment
wildstar is overwhelmingly attractive
the next it's just overwhelming sadly
III is almost here and is a bit of an
obstacle to the wildstar review process
but in advance of the review I wanted to
share a few impressions of my time with
this massively multiplayer role-playing
game and honestly most of that time has
been quite positive wildstar is not
breaking new ground its fundamentals are
firmly entrenched in the formula we've
come to expect in which you take quests
go and kill monsters team up with others
and go looking for treasure out in a big
unknown world but wildstar delivers the
expected with huge doses of character
and glee the brief character quips are
charmingly delivered the quest givers
aren't averse to cracking a few jokes
and some of the adventuring
circumstances are simply adorable the
game's story is quite typical leading
you through the details of the fight
between two factions the Exiles and the
Dominion but I admit I'm invested in
part because I witnessed the Dominion
bomb a giant tree called the elder root
the elder root was kindly when we talked
in his biomechanical design made him
stand out from all those other
giant world trees that show up in games
I cared more about that darn tree than I
ever cared about the Elder Scrolls
online blands talkative characters I'm
ready for vengeance there are eight
races to choose from in six total
classes I'm a spell slinger which is a
bit of a misleading name since pistols
are my primary weapons the extensive
skill trees make me equally adept at
being a damaged heavy class or a healer
and while I usually stick to damage I've
found some fun and healing my teammates
in the insanely chaotic player versus
player matches all of my attacks are
cone based so I never need to
specifically target enemies whatever
lands in my damaged area is unlucky
enough to get hit this system keeps me
mobile since enemies also signal their
most powerful attacks in a similar
manner but that's particularly true in
the two competitive arenas I've unlocked
so far which keep me constantly on the
go so that I can avoid incoming attacks
while staying in range of my teams
healers it's terrific fun though I admit
that the busy visuals can make it tough
to stay in control look out for review
in a few weeks time but if you're on the
fence so far and are curious about what
I think I must say wildstar isn't
overflowing with brand new ideas but
it's fun to play gives me a lot to look
at gives me a lot of ways to cooperate
and compete with others and aside from
the long queue times I sometimes get
stuck dealing with when I first log in
it's mostly stable and feels feature
complete wildstar's a game I could see
myself sticking with at the end game
content is compelling enough if only
because I like uncovering new sights
sounds and adventures
welcome
you